[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
véronique roger médecin généraliste vous
êtes également délégué et santé chez
debout la france bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés pierre-jean
ternes amian radiologue élus huerre ps
médecins libéraux en région rhône-alpes
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
donc feu vert est même show de
recommandations pour administrer une une
troisième dose de la part de là à ce
qu'ils craignaient cette fameuse
troisième dose on en parlait souvent
risque de revoir donc ce spectre devant
eux elle et elle est justifiée sur le
plan sanitaire véronique roger selon
vous
mais écoutez d'abord je voulais dire que
je n'avais aucun conflit d'intérêt je
pense que c'est important quand les
médecins s'exprime de pouvoir le dire
cette histoire de troisième dose pour
moi ce que ça m'évoque c'est que ben
c'est le co vide n'a pas l'air d'être
une maladie très très immunisante
puisque et le vaccin n'est pas très très
protecteur non plus puisque au bout de
quelques mois six mois environ ben moi
j'ai bien vu dans la pratique que
certaines personnes n'avaient plus
d'anticorps ou très peu mais j'ai vu
aussi les gens qui en avaient toujours
énormément et les anticorps continuer à
monter
donc cette troisième dos et des
anticorps chez des gens des patients des
gens des personnels soignants qui ont
toujours des anticorps moi je pour moi
c'est pas de la médecine on se précipite
dans cette folie vaccinale à vacciner
des gens qui ont des anticorps là
vraiment je ne comprends pas à quoi
c'est pas c'est pas médicale dans toutes
les autres maladies quand on a des
anticorps on ne fait pas de vaccin
derrière bon ben là c'est pareil les
gens se précipitent sur la troisième
dose j'ai des personnes des patients
âgés qui vont vers la troisième dose
parce qu'ils sont convoqués mais je
regarde dans leur dossier j'aurais fait
une sérologie ils ont des anti corps au
plafond si vous n'allez pas faire une
troisième dose avec des anticorps au
plafond alors moi je veux bien que l'
agence européenne de médicaments
recommande cette troisième dose mais bon
moi je fais de la médecine voilà
pierre jeantet remaniant c'est vrai que
quand on écoute le docteur roger on se
dit c'est quand même du bon sens ça veut
dire que on va faire une troisième dose
parce qu'on va évidemment conditionné le
pass and i terrassa troisième dose
certainement en tout cas on en prend le
chemin même si pour le moment à la la ça
a bien précisé que c'était prématuré
voilà quelle est votre opinion justement
de médecins pro vaccination
je pense que si vous voulez la france a
déjà un problème c'est que on plafonne
niveau de la vaccination de complète de
12 on n'est qu'à 75% et si vous regardez
la courbe et les plates donc on arrive
on a un niveau de résistance représenté
par à peu près 25% de la population je
rappelle simplement à tous ceux qui sont
les détracteurs de la vaccination ce qui
s'est passé excusez moi en martinique la
réunion en guadeloupe en guyane
au brésil où une couverture vaccinale
quasiment risible malheureusement à 20%
22% dans les dom tom alors peut-être
pour des motifs historiques liées à des
produits qu'ils avaient utilisé
autrefois pour se protéger protéger les
plantations blain en tous les cas avec
22% si vous voulez de vaccination on a
été obligé de faire du tri comme en
médecine militaire pour les patients
atteints de komi donc tout le monde sait
et ce n'est pas une nouveauté et le
chant consoeur le sait aussi klein
capacité va dire unitaires baissent avec
le temps et avec l'acs donc c'est
logique toutes les agences qu'elles sont
recueillies française ou la chaise
demande à terme qu'il y ait pas
forcément tout de suite bien évidemment
puisque la publication française vient
juste d'avoir sa deuxième hausse
quasiment pour la majorité d'entre eux
il faut prévoir d'emblée une troisième
dose et puis il faut effectivement
généraliser et rendre obligatoire la
vaccination ça ne choque personne que
les gosses soient vaccinés ça ne choque
personne car professionnels de santé et
une obligation vaccinale l'hépatite b ça
ne choque personne qui voulait en guyane
d'aller des vacciner contre la fièvre
jaune ou non de court alors
effectivement il ya des motifs on voit
une grogne d'une partie de la population
mais je pense qu'il faut pas mélanger la
politique et la santé des trentenaires
et ça c'est un monument
parce qu'on voit aussi bien dit c'est
une un parti de gauche qui demandent les
vaccinations la droite votre compte si
c'était la droite qui avait demandé sa
légaux j'aurai le décompte mais on
n'entend pas que ces systèmes en france
véronique roger votre réponse parce
qu'il ya plein d'éléments 1 dans ce que
nous donne pierre-jean tard magnan qui
regrette manifestement que les
socialistes n'aient pas eu gain de cause
aujourd'hui sur cette vaccination
obligatoire
d'abord moi je voulais préciser que
contrairement à ce que dit mon confrère
c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre je suis
pas du tout anti vaccins
ou gelée même prescrit ce vaccin optique
au vide les prescrits incertaine des
patients mais de manière ciblée je pense
que il faut c'est le bénéfice risque
dans a toujours appris seulement nos
études la vaccination c'est une affaire
de bénéfice/risque commençons d'abord
par les patients à risque et on a bien
vu que les patients à risque c'était
principalement les personnes âgées les
diabétiques
et puis les obèses bien sûr ça et
évidemment les gens pour des
comorbidités donc si les gens ont
commencé par ces personnes là
avant de se précipiter sur les jeunes je
sais pas pour moi c'est une aberration
de se précipiter sur les jeunes d'autant
plus que moi je parle de ma pratique je
la suis pas en tant que politique là je
suis en tant que médecin généraliste je
parle de ma pratique et faut voir tous
les effets secondaires que j'ai vu grave
évidemment je parle pas de la petite
rougeur ou de la petite
petite douleur au bras je parle d'effets
secondaires graves moi j'en ai vu
énormément je suppose que tous mes
collègues m'ont vu aussi le problème
c'est qu'il est déclare port moi je
déclare bon et et je trouve ça énorme
donc il faut cibler la vaccination oui
tout à fait d'accord je suis producteur
ti'vac sa part et d'autre part quels
effets
secondaires
ben moi j'ai vu des effets graves j'ai
vu des insuffisances cardiaques j'ai
fait un infarctus j'ai vu des troubles
du rythme j'ai vu une thyroïdite auto
immunes j'ai vu un zona chez un petit un
petit adolescent de 12 ans et demi un
énorme zone à
c'est parce qu'on est en train de faire
mais bon
et puis et puis aussi et énormément de
covin post vaccination parce que mon
confrère dit qu'il faut vacciner
vacciner vacciner mais on sait très bien
que la vaccination tous vaccinés tous
protégés c'est pas vrai on connaît tous
dans notre entourage mais je pense
vraiment tous moi j'en connais
énormément qui sont venus me raconter
qu'ils s'étaient vacciner et qui ont eu
qu'ovide juste derrière donc on sait
très bien que ce n'est pas dans sa forme
grave parce que c'est ce qu'on dit on
n'a jamais dit que oui c'est d'avoir le
combiné mais de finir à l'hôpital c'est
ce qui est dit en tout cas ça c'est un
jeune un jeune loup une personne de 40
45 ans qui n'a aucune maladie n'a pas un
risque énorme de faire une forme grave
loin de là autre ère et bien faire une
ferme légère alors si on veut aussi la
parole parce que c'est important ce sont
des arguments
la même opinion et c'est important de
donner aussi la parole à pierre jeantet
remaniant sur ses effets secondaires
docteur tard magnan premièrement et
deuxièmement sur la deuxième partie de
la réponse de votre consoeur votre
réponse
réponse est très simple et je vais
l'inversé
clairement si vous voulez c'est un peu
désobligeant pour les martiniquais ou
les réunionnais où les guadeloupéens les
considérer que tous comme mauvaise vieux
et avec une unité déprimé à 22 % de la
couverture vaccinale il ya eu des
dizaines de morts par jour des gens en
bonne santé qui est jaune 20 ans 30 ans
40 ans en martinique parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de couverture vaccinale vous
ne pouvez pas dire que vous allez
sélectionner les patients cette maladie
tue est d'autant plus que celle variant
delta
sur les effets secondaires
encore faut-il avoir une étude correct
qui vérifie bien que suite à la rétine à
sion il ya eu des problèmes et pour ça
il faut référence il est calé déclaré et
attendre de voir ce qui se passe les
voir keller née l'analyse parce que on
peut effectivement vous dire que je fais
des récits où je suis un infarctus de
mieux qu'un il faut être un peu on peut
dire
à nice
les problèmes qu'on a eus sur la
vaccination sont tout à fait mineurs
contrairement à ce que vous affirmez sur
le rapport bénéfice risque parce qu'on a
évité et on a tu cassez en france
métropolitaine une quatrième vague qui
aurait été sinon aussi forte que la
troisième vague avec des centaines de
morts et on n'a pas mis à jour le
système de santé au moment
clairement charnière du mois d'août où
les coincer de santé que nous sommes on
était tous épuisés ou deux ans quasiment
sans vacances au front en d'autres
termes c'est au front qu'on était et on
a quelques uns ont pu prendre des
vacances et à ce moment là on se
retrouve avec une quatrième essai était
la panique à bord on s'est dit si jamais
ça recommence à monter comme la
troisième la 2e la première vaincre que
fécond on a déjà réquisitionné les gens
on n'a pas arrêté d'envoyer des avions
chargés de soigner un matériel aussi
bien poulain guadeloupe la martinique la
réunion maintenant la nouvelle calédonie
et on l'a fait pour tahiti parce que eux
aussi étaient soi-disant protéger nuit
par leur isolement sauf que le virus
bascule aujourd'hui en tout cas quand on
regarde les chiffres on va les regarder
d'ailleurs les voir de santé publie
france on se dit que l'épidémie est
plutôt sous contrôle un regard des 1475
hospitalisation sur les sept derniers
jours 262 admission en réanimation 62
décès hier
justement se dire on peut marquer le pas
sur la vaccination est ce vraiment le
bon moment de parler de la de la
troisième dose docteur roger
ben moi je vous dis
cette affaire de troisième dose chez des
gens et me disais je comprends pas après
donc nous offrir me dit qu'il était en
première ligne moi aussi j'étais en
première ligne vous savez j'en ai vu des
copies d'un
l'année dernière surtout parce que cette
année pas tellement et c'était pas du
tout les mêmes qu'au vide
j'en ai tellement vu que je les attrape
et moi même et donc je suis donc
immunisés et donc je vois pas pourquoi
je me ferai vacciner voilà séidou d'où
le fait que je ne je n'ai plus droit des
xes d'exercer en ce moment ce qui est
comble dans une ville où il ya pas du
tout de médecins alors que je suis pas
du tout dangereuse ni responsable comme
les teints mats dilma député a dit que
j'étais dangereuse et irresponsable
je pense que moi je suis sûr que je ne
suis pas du tout donc je ne comprends
pas cette politique voilà moi je fais de
la médecine je vois mes patients je les
soigne d'ailleurs parce qu'on a tout
misé sur le vaccin mais il ya quand même
des traitements qui marche très bien
donc si on soigne les gens si haut si on
développe les les hôpitaux parce que
vous parlez d'une première mais la
qualité des hôpitaux fin faudrait que
l'état se préoccupe de la qualité des
hôpitaux si on veut soigner les gens
fous quand même déjà qui est des
hôpitaux correct or là on continue en
france à fermer des lits voilà il ya des
soignants qui sont éjectés avec une
violence
sans pareille par l'état qui fait de la
médecine à la place des médecins ils
sont éjectés du jour au lendemain on
sait même pas quel est notre devenir il
ya les hôpitaux il ya des services dans
les hôpitaux en france qui ne sont
obligés de travailler à mi-temps tout
fermé parce qu'il ya des soignants qui
sont absents
ouais moi je moi je comprends pas cette
politique là la manière
comment justifier l'administration d'une
troisième dose alors qu'on n'a justement
pas atteindre la ville d'yzeure 74%
100% de la vaccination ça veut dire en
gros ceux qui sont déjà vaccinés vont se
faire piquer pour pour les autres pour
déclencher cette fameuse immunité c'est
ça l'idée non pas tout à fait le
problème c'est que la vaccination a
débuté je dirais en janvier 2021 on
arrive au bout d'une année où on sait
très bien parce que c'est un vaccin qui
n'a pas une durée on veut dire
d'efficacité on veut dire qu'il va
s'affaiblir un peu comme le vaccin de la
grippe qui arrive avec à chaque fois une
mutation potentiellement différentes on
sait qu'au bout d'un an limité m'avait
c'est donc le principe même de la
vaccination c'est la prévention
soit on continue cet effort gigantesque
qui a été fait pour protéger la
population française et éviter qu'ils
arrivent dans des hôpitaux qui par
ailleurs ont des problèmes que l'on
connaît tous que ce soit d'ailleurs les
hôpitaux privés ou privés et il est
cabinet univers où les médecins libéraux
sont au monde ont des soucis je dirais
majeur actuellement à à gérer et à
essayer on va dire de survivre mais dans
ce schéma-là la vaccination c'est de la
prévention devant l'arrivée au moment où
effectivement il faut commencer la
troisième dose et surtout pousser des
feux pour que les 25% dirait du tibre il
ya un défaut on va dire oui
incompréhension sur la stratégie
vaccinale et puis vous n'empêcherez pas
une partie de la population de mélanger
la santé et la folie et ça c'est l'hymne
amant dangereux alors sur l'immunité qui
baisse à un dernier mot sur le vaccin
13h pas mal d'études montrent justement
que son efficacité diminue avec le temps
bout peut-être cette question de la
troisième dose qui nous pend au nez le
vaccin est efficace à regarder on va le
voir sur ces images à 88% les six
premiers mois
47% les six mois suivants
clairement est ce qu'on utilise déjà le
bon produit là on va pas refaire le
débat sur la vaccination mais déjà ce
qu'on utilise le bon produit est ce
qu'on est elle est peut-être trop vite
dans le choix des vaccins le docteur
roger selon vous
alors je vais peut-être encore choqué
mon confrère en disant que
ça a été aussi vite c'est parce que
justement ce ne sont pas des vaccins
ce sont des injections
susceptible de donner des anticorps oui
ça donne des anticorps mais on est
toujours en phase de test on est
toujours en phase 3 deux de ces vaccins
jusqu'en 2022 2023 donc déjà je vois pas
comment on peut rendre obligatoire
quelque chose qui est encore en phase de
test
pierre-jean tard avions justement sur le
choix des vaccins avec cette immunité
qui diminue qui va peut-être nous
pousser à faire c'est justement cette
troisième dose
s'est tournée je dirais l'exemple
d'israël qui avait utilisé de façon
massive et qui commence à avoir une
troisième dose et qui vous oblige vous
allez aller dans son territoire à avoir
vous donnons une dose de rappel c'est
une dose de rappel après moi je
préciserai simplement trop filimone en
israël justement est-ce qu'on ne s'est
pas précipité sur sur le choix de pizzas
non aux comptes et sur les riders
d'ailleurs si vous les gars il ya un
avant et après vaccination liés aux arn
messager il ya dix ans cette équipe on
va dire allemande a réussi à m on va
dire une thérapie pour les cancers du
poumon qui était en phase terminale et
qui marche sur et ils se sont basés sur
cette idée de la rn message est
d'utiliser cette technique qui sont des
vies pour essayer d'aller beaucoup plus
vite parce que si on est dans le schéma
vaccinal classique genre sanofi par
exemple sur des vaccins dits
traditionnels
automatiquement dès que durée
d'élaboration de un an et demi quand on
a une pandémie qui vous arrive à vitesse
grand v et puis une vague 2 bac 3 vannes
en moins d'un an vous n'avez pas le
temps de faire un bac 5 et sanofi en est
un très bon exemple
sanofi a fait un choix il ya dix ans en
arrière 12 ans n'a rien de ne pas
investir
regardez les centaines de millions
d'euros qu'ils investissent actuellement
dans la technologie air et ça va nous
permettre non seulement de reprofiler un
vaccin ans six semaines mais ça va
peut-être nous donner des vaccins contre
le paludisme ou d'autres thérapies qui
vont émerger parce qu'il y avait un
avant et un après la rn messager et ça
donne une protection et pfizer est
manifestement pour ceux qui ont une mono
doses
on leur donne deux ans pour avoir et
pour ma consoeur c'est clair que ayant
vu le kobe de l'an dernier la deuxième
dose serait bénéfique probablement pour
elle au moment où sont évités va baisser
et elle va forcément baisser parce
qu'elle est pas je dirais éternel
l'immunité d'un pour ce type de
pathologie ce qui est par les thérapies
pour d'autres vaccins et
on n'a pas le choix on prend le meilleur
on va dire actuellement sur le marché
alors on est bien effectivement fast
mois les échanges le est ce que vous
imaginez le nombre de gens qu'on a déjà
pu sauver
oui un petit mot peut-être faire une
étrange et ça sera la fin s'il vous
plaît
oui bah écoutez moi je pense que j'ai
sauvé des gens aussi avec des
traitements précoces et encore une fois
je suis pas du tout je suis pas anti
vaccins je dis qu'il faut être prudent
en médecine il faut quand même être
prudent il ya toute une toute une gamme
de solutions avant de se précipiter dans
cette folie vaccinale et moi de toute
façon
je ne souhaite pas d'une société de de
contrôle de flicage de surveillance
d'obligations voilà moi c'est pas ma
manière de voir la société et on est en
train de balancier vers cette société
complètement inhumaine alors comme moi
je pense que le plus important c'est la
liberté c'est la vérité j'espère que la
vérité va va éclater et puis quand même
là les relations humaines là on est
tombé dans une société où il faut
quasiment se dénoncer les uns les autres
si on est vacciné pourrait finir sa
soirée micro de la wii mais c'est
important oui bah c'est pour ça qu'on
vous donne la parole véronique anger
précisément vous avez pu apporter
totalement votre opinion en toute
liberté ce soir sur ce plateau avec le
docteur pierre jean therme agnant merci
en tout cas à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté ce face à face